ces 2021 copenhagen
[Music]
yeah no this is just a green screen in
my basement welcome to ces 2021
yes the usually in las vegas consumer
tech show is happening entirely online
this year
so i'm covering it from here with my dog
he's not helping very much and obviously
in my slippers but this is in fact a new
connected mask that's been introduced at
the tech show
and this is a new smart doorbell with a
thermometer built in
and this is a new mini air purifier
unsurprisingly gadgets that try to
protect you from
browser decide where you're going to sit
at home production
unsurprisingly gadgets that try to
protect you from coven 19 and
gross germs in general are a pretty big
deal at this year's show
and i decided to try to get some shipped
to my home
anyway these anti-covet gadgets which
fall into three different categories
are pretty out there but that's what
makes this ces just like
every other ces number one high
tech masks i'm wearing an air pop
active plus smart mask this circle here
isn't a filter those come with the mask
and clip inside
this thing contains sensors that capture
breathing related data
temperature and humidity then via
bluetooth it delivers that data to your
phone
so you can know more about your
breathing and the outside world
the airpop app will also tell you when
it's time to change the mask's filter
unfortunately the first one i got broke
the sensor stopped powering on
the second one worked fine which means i
could finally use the app to change the
color led
which is pretty much the coolest thing
about this thing the 150 dollar mask
will be available in february
150 for a mask it's a lot to breathe in
there's also this mask phone which i've
actually been using for the last month
or so
it has a built-in headset so you can
make calls hey it's joanna i'm calling
you for my mask
lg's also announced this purecare
wearable air purifier
which looks like it's straight out of
the dark knight rises
where are the other big tech companies
with masks
apple does make this non-smart mask and
it's actually quite comfortable
considering it's covering so much of my
face
but it's only available to apple
employees no eye mask for you
number two uv sanitizers for everything
uv sanitizers for your smartphone are a
dime a dozen but what about your
disgusting keyboard and mouse
the targus uvc led disinfection light
has a purple ultraviolet light to kill
bacteria and germs that live on surfaces
it's designed to turn on and run for
five minutes every hour
the device's motion sensor disables
cleaning if it detects your hands or any
other movement
it will be available for 299 dollars in
march or april
the issue with any uv cleaning gadget
the devices don't look any cleaner
afterwards though the science is proven
you have to take the manufacturer's
claim at face value
and because germs can travel through the
air lg's purecare mini air purifier can
be worn
around your wrist it pairs with your
smartphone via bluetooth so you can
control what mode it is in
and see information about the
cleanliness of the air
it's 200 and available now there's also
this luft duo which the company claims
is the world's smallest molecular air
purifier
number three temperature sensors option
one
tape a thermometer to your door and
don't let anyone in until they've
reported their body temp
option two get the eddie doorbell from a
company named plot
it's exactly what you think it is a
smart doorbell with a connected camera
and a built-in infrared temperature
sensor
in the app you can see live video of the
person at your door
and a reading of their temperature i was
sent this non-working unit so i wasn't
able to test it out
the company says it'll be available for
300 at the end of 2021.
if you're not into that doorbell there's
also this 369 dollar gate dock
a freestanding thermometer aimed at
businesses
so take your pick of your covid19
protection gadget
or just stay in your basement and play
video games
bye